[Music]
take a look black pieces and what we can
do to beat it with white of course I'm
talking about the Banco gambit it's a
popular response to d4 and it gets into
a very unique type of position
it's the the Banco gambit is a pretty
unique opening in that it you don't see
it really transposed into other things a
lot of the time and the main variations
at least and so it's worth taking a look
at worth getting familiar with the Banco
gambit because a lot of principles that
you might have from other openings
aren't really going to be super
effective here so you need to take a
look and see what the ideas are and
that's what we're gonna take a look at
today
so d49 f6 c4 c5 this is the key move
order in the Banco gambit now if you're
afraid of the micro gamete there's a lot
of things you can do we could play a
move like III if you want to avoid it
play even a move like Knight f3 but of
course we're not afraid we're going
right into it so d5 b5 and I'm gonna
recommend you play the Bunco gambit
fully accepted that's right you take all
the free pawns and then you're doing
quite well so we take on these basics
now black can recapture immediately but
perhaps the most accurate move orders to
play g6 first now there's no real buy
for white to defend this pawn
comfortably so you just play Knight c3
now black will in fact capture on a6 and
now after E for Bishop takes f1 King
takes f1 this is part of the point of
the Bunco gambit for black yeah makes a
white recapture on f1 with the King and
waste some time fixing his King here so
d6 net f3 this is all the main main main
line Bishop g7 g3 black castles white
plays King G to essentially
thing by hands black plays Knight bd7
and then the line I'm gonna recommend is
the line that was played in this game
between Magnus Carlsen and Victor
Bulacan and that line actually starts
with the move 12 a four and it might
seem a little bit silly to denote a line
in the opening by the twelfth move but
up to this point both sides have been
playing really that the main main line
this is really how the Bangko game it
goes with very few deviations along the
way there are some side lines the black
can try but this is really the main
setup of the Benko
Knight of 6 this Knight to d7 and then
from here black has a few various
options that we're gonna look at today
but this is kind of our main starting
position and this move a four probably
looks a little bit unnatural at first
you're giving up for example this B
Foursquare and generally when you see an
A and a B pawn the way they kind of get
pushed is like a 3 B 4 and then you go
from there but the idea of a 4 is really
targeted at just shutting down blacks
counter play really the heart of the
Benko gambit is you give up this pawn on
the Queen side and in return you get
these two nice open files and black
tries to make use of the major pieces on
these open files in order to put
pressure on the pawns to win the pawns
back even and to just have a very very
active play additionally this Bishop on
g7 is a very strong piece and it works
quite well in tandem with those major
pieces on these two files so how does
that relate to us playing a4 well we
play a four to take control of the be 5
square now that we control b5 we might
be able to plant a knight onto this
square
and with this set up we're aiming to get
kind of a blockade on the Queen side so
that these black major pieces actually
don't have any way to break through with
that in mind Magnus did not play a floor
in this game and said he played Queen e2
but now after Queen b6 and a4 we have
actually transposed to to the mainland
so a little bit more natural of a way to
get here is to play a four first then
Queen B 6 and then Queen e2 but it
doesn't really matter how you get there
in the ends and just so long as you get
there so a four and now Rick FB 8 by
black is keeping in line with this
strategy and now Magnus plays the main
move the the most natural move simply
Knight b5 you shove this knight in the
way of the black major pieces and you
try to keep him from from getting in any
kind of play so with night b5 it looks
as though White's blockade is going to
be pretty pretty difficult to to you
know dismantle black in the game tried
98 which is still the main move white
responded with Bishop g5 also the main
line and now Bishop g5 of course is
attacking this pawn on e7 so black has
to defend it somewhere somehow King f8
is a main move in the game black played
Queen d8 and I did just want to briefly
mention this sidelines with h6 just
giving up this pawn on e7 but in return
this Bishop gets a little bit stuck on
this e 7 square and so this is kind of
worth taking a look at here and there's
quite a few games white ends up with a
little bit of an advantage I want to say
I like this move g4 in this position for
weight threatening to get the bishop out
I don't want to go too deep into this
kind of crazy line here today but that's
worth taking a look at if you don't know
any of the theory after age 6 well you
can kind of simply just retreat this
Bishop back to e3 if you want back to c1
even if you want even back to d2 and
give up this pawn if you like with some
counter play on this Queen side but
that's beside the point in the game
Queen d8 was played with a more normal
kind of Benko looking looking position
in the game white plays this move rook
a3 and this is a pretty strange
strange-looking move I would like to
turn it over to the chat I'd like to ask
you guys
if you can see the idea behind rook a
three-y was Rick a three played in the
game what do you think
why rook a3 in particular what is white
hoping to do here
does anybody have any idea I'll give you
just a moment longer rook b3 says Gil
wolf rook b3 not actually going to be
the main idea here because the b2 pond
was pinned that's actually close to the
truth that is a hundred percent correct
rook a3 unpinned the beep on and that's
a main reason for right playing rk3 but
why do we want to push the beep on and
where do we want to push it to you know
what's the what's the purpose so yeah
you get out of the pin but still protect
the a pawn but why do we want to push
the beep on what do we want to do with
it
it also does allow ideas of doubling up
on the a file but that's a little bit
beside the point here the main reason we
want to play your k3 as you guys said is
because it frees up this B pond we allow
this pond to move a little bit a little
bit more freely and in this case we're
looking to bring it to the b3 square so
for example if white continues with
Knight b6 as was played in the game we
simply want to play b3 and this is a
really good move for white for a couple
of reasons number one it defends the a
floorpan this is kind of the most
natural idea but number two it controls
a very very important square in the
Benko gambit and that is the C 4 square
a very common way for black to kind of
break open the white structure and get
his pieces into the game is to play this
move c4 and follow it up
usually by bringing a Knight to e5 and
into d3 things of this nature in this
case the the night on b6 also pressures
a 4 with another idea behind this c4
move it also breaks open another file
for these black major pieces to invade
along since white has done a very nice
job of blocking up the a and the B files
so the c-4 square is gonna be a really
crucial square for both sides in this
Benko gambit so b3 does a nice job of
defending that pawns this is a really
useful maneuver to keep in mind bringing
this rook up to a3 and following up with
this move not B takes a three but rather
pollen to b3 so in the game we did see
York a 396 in b3 now black plays this
move Queen d7 and I would have actually
liked to see instead from black perhaps
the move knight c7 is required this is a
pretty common idea in the Benko you need
to get rid of this knight on b5 to
activate black pieces and so nicely 7 is
a good way to do it
white would probably capture and then
play Knight d2 once again it's all about
this c4 square and then from here it
would still just be a game the game
would continue but at least this
powerful Knight on
five is kind of out of the way for black
a bit but let's stick to what happened
in the game Queen d7 instead now Magnus
plays the slightly strange-looking rook
a - just to get this rook on a square
root it's defended and allowed some more
mobility now the move f6 comes on the
board by black kicking this bishop back
to c1 and now black kind of commits to a
structural deficit here he wants to
break down the white pawns but in doing
so he kind of sacrifices his own King
position but the fact is he kind of has
to there's really no other way to go
about playing here and that move that he
plays is f5 so f5 really breaks open the
white center and this is a nice way for
black to try to find counter play but as
I said it's it's giving up a lot it's
really weakening the black King and
we'll see Magnus manage to take
advantage of that I did want to briefly
mention well what happened if black
doesn't go crazy with this f6i f5 idea
and if that's the case then probably
still he should go back to this NAEYC 7
plan when we would take playing 92 and
after a move like 97 like I said if
black is just playing naturally white
can play naturally as well we bring a
look over to the beef file and just as
an example line something like this may
occur and Knight takes e4
I mean takes c4 and the fact is white
has totally consolidated and it's just
up a clean pawn and now I want to pause
here for a moment and see if you guys
can find the the key idea for white to
make use of this extra pawn I would say
white had salt has some solidly left the
opening from this stage and can you know
kept his extra pawn but how can he make
use of it what is the key break in this
position for the white player what is
the key break
and then yeah there's a question on
Roque three versus four okay - so I'll
jump back to there to take a look at it
but here it's the key way for a white to
advance yeah Gil wolf has it White's
idea with this extra pawn is eventually
going to be this move be four so you can
imagine move like Queen b6 maybe and we
can even respond with b4 immediately I
could take white could take and at the
end of the day once we reach a position
like this it really well and truly is an
extra pawn with no compensation for
black and the game is probably gonna
continue with white pushing this pawn up
the board and then trying to make use of
this Bishop and this should be a pretty
easy game for white I believe it's
winning it might not be the easiest one
ever for everybody out there but you
know you can't really ask for for more
than a winning position out of the
opening so this example line was just to
show how the game might progress if
black doesn't really strike in the
center immediately if black is just
taking his time
well why it's just gonna bring his
pieces over to the Queen side and play
for B floor this is your go to plan once
you kind of slow down the black rush of
pieces
slow down blacks attacking ideas b4 is
the way to advance your own plan if
black hasn't really proven anything now
back here there was a question of why
would you play rook a3 if you could just
play rook a to instead and the answer is
a little bit tricky
maybe this knight c7 idea actually grows
in power a little bit
for example takes and takes and now just
for example it's a little bit difficult
to play b3 without your rook on a3
because you're not defending it and so
you can imagine move like Rick b1 but
now something like before and again
it's tough to play b3 because you're
running into some danger so for the
moment it is sometimes useful to have
this rook on a3 to defend this beep on
but after Knight b6 that defense of the
beep on is a little bit less required
because this Knights a little bit in the
of blackstone pieces which is why Magnus
was free to bring the rook back to a -
it's a good question though it's a good
question so back to the game
black did not kind of sit back and wait
for white to play very naturally and win
in the classic Bunco style instead in
this game black plays this move f5 to
challenge the white center and now
tactically this just ends up being
pretty good for Magnus Magnus takes on
f5 and black recaptures on f5 with the
pawn so what has black gained by this
maneuver
well he's gained a weakness on the d5
square what has black lost well now
these squares around the King are just
feeling a little bit open and in
addition to that this backwards pawn on
e7 might come under fire for the moment
Magnus simply defends his D pawn and
black plays Knight f6 adding another
attacker and it turns out this is a
pretty difficult attacker for Magnus to
meet it's true that Magnus could just
play the move Knight c3 and keep this
guy defended but perhaps he didn't want
to take such a passive role in the game
Knight c3 is very good for white don't
get me wrong
but instead Magnus chooses Queen e6
check to change the structure up a
little bit black captures and white
captures and now we have another change
in structure here with white having this
very far advanced pawn on e6 now it
might look a little bit overextended but
the classic saying as always is it's
only weakness if you can attack it and
it looks pretty tough for black to get a
hold of this one and in addition to
being so far advanced on e6 attacking
key squares it also blocks off this pawn
on e7 a bit and really just ends up
winning this pawn by force there's no
way for black to defend this pawn as we
see in the game black plays 94 and
Magnus simply plays Knight h4 and as I
said this pawn is just a goner no real
way to defend it if you play a move like
rook f8 you're just taking a little bit
too passive of an approach stuff like a
five-night c7
and 95 are going to come and you're
really really on the backfoot here this
is just kind of devastating
so black chooses to give up this pun and
plays see for his key break and while
it's true that Magnus allowed c4 at the
end of the day Magnus is winning this f5
pun and it's well worth it well well
worth it so B takes e4 and Knight takes
e4 and then Magnus actually throws in
night c7 rather than capturing the F
pawn black gets a little bit tricky here
plays the move Knight c3 forking the
white rooks so white takes a rook black
takes a rook and now white your treats
black retreats white saves his rook
black plays works e8 and white brings
the knight back to b5 and I don't want
to talk too much about the specific of
these tactics the the point of the
lecture is kind of a bent go gambit and
here Magnus already has a winning
advantage so why don't we just see how
he converted black captured on b5 white
captured and after rook c5 we see rook
b3 somehow someway black actually did
manage to take this pawn it was just
never worth it to Magnus to uh to
capture it but the story of the game is
really gonna be this past beep on once
again this is the classic way to win in
the Benko you keep your extra pawn and
then you push it in the endgame and
simply win Knight a5 was played rook b1
defends the bishop bishop d4 now B 697
to blockade this jerk comes up to b4 we
see black tactically win a pawn back
with this Bishop move take stakes or
sorry it takes check and then takes but
now after Knight takes f5 white is still
up upon and this is just dead lost in
the game black played Knight c5 just
giving up the night after b7 and
resigned if he tries something else like
rook e1 for example well rook c4 is
gonna be a really good move threatening
some checkmates and this rook is just
going to invade and if nothing else we
still have b7 just winning the night so
with all that in mind Magnus won this
game pretty easily there were some
pretty complicated complex tactics in
there in the middle but the point I
wanted to get across
is black went for this f6f-5 idea trying
to complicate things but really in my
opinion this was more of a last-ditch
effort than an actual winning plan black
saw that white had really consolidated
over on the queenside he saw that the
the moves of like c4 were never really
going to get him anywhere and white had
a very nice lock on the position so
rather than just wait sit back and allow
Magnus to do whatever he wants
black tried this f6f-5 idea to
complicate things turns out it just
wasn't good for him so that is my first
introduction to the Benko here with this
game we see white blockade on the B file
and stop these black major pieces from
getting through and then black kind of
panics plays this f5 move and ends up
losing why don't we take a look at a
slightly different variation in another
game by some grandmasters this one was
between Alexander lunderman who now
lives in the st. Louis area actually and
Palouse of course this game started with
the Benko and we fully accept it as I
was saying I also want to say you know
once again there really aren't too many
deviations along this line for black
there's 1,300 games in this database
that I'm looking at here and in all that
seven of them black captured on that one
here so like really this is the only
line and then then almost all the games
d6 was played and almost all the games
Bishop g7 is played almost all the games
castles played and the knight bt7 is
played I almost always and then we
arrived at this position with 12a for
which as I said it's kind of the
starting position of this line in the
Banco Sol last game we took a look at
what happened after Queen b6 and Queen
e2 and we saw that white put this knight
on b5 very very quickly played rook a3
played b3 and got a blockhead
so in this game black tried a slightly
different setup playing the second most
common move with rook a6 and this move
looks slightly strange but it's just a
different way of ordering the black
major pieces to put a slightly different
amount of pressure
on the White Queen side and so we're
gonna see what the the differences are
here with rook a six black is actually
telegraphing that he wants to play the
move Queen a eight doubling up actually
on the a file this is how he is putting
pressure so rather than the movie saw in
the previous game with Queen e2 to guard
the EEP on we're going to play the move
Queen c2 in this case and this move just
adds an extra defender to the a pawn
helps preemptively alleviate some of
that pressure Queen a8 was played and
now rook a3 is still going to be the
natural idea for white rook c8 is now
actually the move played in the game and
this move looks a little bit strange you
know you might expect black to bring the
rook to the B file but actually the move
rook b8 would be a bit of a mistake here
I think due to Knight b5 when you have
nothing better than to guard this square
again I was gonna say nothing but in the
burgh c8 but rook d7 is probably a bit
better and the rook actually simply
belongs on the c8 square where it can
help support the c4 break as we've said
already white now plays very naturally
just brings this rook over to the D to
the D file and now black plays the move
Knight g4 and I did want to mention that
in this position it's still totally fine
totally playable to play move like 95
but I think practically it just doesn't
make quite as much sense here our goal
with Knight B 5 in the first game was to
block off this B file block down lock
down the B file pressure in this case
the black is not really pressuring down
the B file so I don't really see a need
to play the move Knight b5 and that's
why I liked what white did in this game
simply playing b3 getting this part of
our plot aid up first blocking off this
c4 square making sure that's not going
to be a problem now the idea of 94 was
to bring this Knight to e5 and black
follows through with that white simply
captures this Knight black captures this
night and just develops this bishop and
I wanted to mention here
it's in this game black actually does
get his key breakthrough with c4 but I
wanted you at home to try and figure out
why this is still good for white why can
white simply allow black to play this
key breaker with c4 what's the
difference here why is this fine
if fragrance I'm actually going to take
a look at a game in one of the and that
line a little bit later this is still
the main line though by it by far this
is what is normally played I think this
a seven line is still a little bit of a
sight line from my understanding but I'm
gonna take a look at one game that I
actually played in that line and yeah
this game was was in the first spring
classic here in st. Louis so why did
white allow c4 what's the difference
it gives black the d3 squared yeah this
is why black wants to play c4 but why is
Wyatt allowing it and Gabriel has one of
the answers and I think the best answer
in this case and that is white can play
this move b4 and this is actually going
to be really powerful for white gaining
these protected pass pawns or connected
passed pawns rather but can get this
night on to the d3 Square and now we
have a really key move here in the move
b5 hitting this rook the rook might come
to a f5 and then it can drop this Bishop
back and really at this point these two
pawns connected and passed are going to
be worth having this strong night on d3
the game might continue for example
something like Queen b7 rook could be
one to support the pawns something like
Bishop e5 and now we might play a move
like b6 and things like Knight b5 are
going to be coming onto the board and
it's going to be very very uncomfortable
for black to deal with in fact the C
pawn might turn out to be a bit of a
weakness after something like night c7
when there's no good way to defend this
guy in the game though white actually
shows a different approach and it really
does highlight that the main point of c4
if if for example black isn't taking on
the B 3 square the main point of it is
in fact to get this night to d3 and
since Alexander Linderman knew this was
the main idea he simply captured this
Knight took it off the board and then
went about his play black inserted the
move C takes b3 and now after Queen
takes b3 Bishop e5 it's true that black
has opened up this C file however
has now traded off some pieces traded
off the strong c4 pawn trail off any
annoying nights and is simply just going
to be up upon it's hard to argue with
this extra pawn in the Banco gambit the
game continued with Knight b5 and from
here I will take a look and see how Alex
managed to convert this position but I
wanted to call this kind of the end of
the opening when white still just has a
very nice advantage with this extra a
pawn it's going to be a very very
pleasant endgame for white if not
winning there's a question couldn't
black and just trade the bishop for the
III Knight and capture the a for pawn
I'm not sure what you mean how do you
mean in this case I am saying Bishop e3
and you were saying can black just take
here and it's a good question tactically
though this doesn't quite work out we
can take this pawn and take this night
and unfortunately your your rook on c8
is hanging good question up but
tactically
white is is prevailing in that case and
I'm not sure there's really a good way
to to prevent this tactic from happening
to black this kind of has to stay here
and you just don't have enough pressure
on the a pawn
so Bishop takes e5 and this is the
position we had in the game and Alex
simply plays rook T to the idea of
probably rook c2 to contest the file
Rick a8 was played Queen d3 and now in
this endgame Alex eventually brings this
rook over to the C file and we see these
pieces come off the board and now after
85 the end is near for black I think
perhaps a slightly better defense would
be to stick this Queen on a5 and try and
blockade this piece a little bit further
but at the end of the day it is just
gonna be an extra pawn for white and in
this pure endgame it's really tough to
say if it's enough to win or not but
it's definitely going to be very very
good winning chances for for white hear
stuff like Queen c4 and then you can
read out this Knight bring the Queen to
b5 and it's it's going to be tough for
black to defend
with that in mind though in the game we
saw a five and now H four from black is
trying to get at the king but simply a
six and now a seven and black has to
divert the rook to stop the pawn and
after H three there's simply not enough
pressure on this King and now e5 is the
final move of the game trapping this
Bishop on f6 blocked by its own pieces
and one white piece and that is where
Viktor be loose resigned this position
giving Lenderman the win so this was
just another classic Benko gambit game
where white blockades everything on the
Queen side locks it all down with this
a4 move and then plays b3 to prevent the
c-4 break and from there simply converts
up upon and that is really all you have
to do to beat the Benko let's say let's
go with one more game here with another
Viktor Viktor Logica this time against
Vlad Christian Giano in this game of
course they played the Benko gambit
believe it or not we're taking a look at
the main line once again and just to
mention someone was saying the main line
these days is with Bishop g7 which
allows white to keep this pawn for the
moment with eventually playing an a7
move and I think we're gonna look take a
look at a game in this line a little bit
later this is really the only deviation
for black is sometimes this Bishop g7
move gets played and there are some
tricks to look out for in that line but
I'm focusing on on the main line mostly
for this lecture and just for reference
bishop xa6 played some 3,000 times
Bishop g7 played around 600 times so not
quite as common but Bishop takes a 6 e
for Bishop takes f1 King takes up 1 d6
Knight f3 and we arrive at our main
position here after the moved a 4 black
should play e6 and try to play on the
long diagonal with the Queen on a8 that
is definitely one idea many but there
was really no no way to go about it in
the previous game so we have looked at
Queen b6 now we've looked at rook
six with queen a8 now and last but not
least we're gonna take a look at this
line with Queen a5 and examine some
ideas here so we're gonna take a look at
Bishop d2 for white the idea is simply
you put the bishop opposite the Queen
and make life for black a little bit
awkward in the game black played rook F
be it which is the main move there are
some other choices here I can bring this
Queen up to a six I can bring this Queen
up to be four but the ideas are gonna
largely be the same but rook b8 has
played now Knight b5 and black actually
drops this Queen all the way back to d8
now in the game white played Queen c2
keeping an eye on this epon as always
and keeping an eye on this a pawn as
well the question of whether or not to
bring the Queen to e2 or to c2 can kind
of be a tough one the way I kind of
think of it is in this Queen b6 line we
bring the Queen to e2 and the other ones
usually see T's just a better square
keeping an eye on this guy as well
keeping an eye on this beep on not being
blocked off by this Bishop 98 and was
played in the game once again this idea
is sometimes to bring this next to c7
also to just open up this bishop in the
game rook a be one was White's choice
and this is kind of the improvement of
this line over the the previous ones
that we've seen in the previous lines
white has had to play rook a3 in order
to defend this a pawn and push b3 in
this line however like only has one
piece attacking the a4 pawn and white is
actually free to just bring this rook to
a better Square on b1 before playing b3
so keep that in mind if you can bringing
the rook to be one is simply going to be
better than wreck a3 with good play
however I don't think black should
really allow this this move order and
you should be forced to play York a3
which is still not bad Knight c7 is
blacks choice in the game white captures
this night on c7 black captures this
night on c7 and then we see rook H to c1
from
white here and once again what do you
think this move rook hc1 is preparing
for what is White's idea to come so the
good gambit for beginners it's a good
gambit because it's it's a playable
opening where black it's playable
position with some counter play for
beginners really I think you can play
just about anything at the beginning
level it's all about getting familiar
with with the chessboard
getting familiar with the pieces getting
that board vision up at the beginner
level so really at the beginner level
just focus more on playing good chess
keeping your pieces safe looking out for
basic tactics don't worry so much about
the opening Roenick Singh seems to have
the answer as the seventh novelty as to
jean as does oh well as does Hashem and
James says prepare for c4 not a bad idea
also keeping an eye on the see
Foursquare but of course what we're
doing is preparing for this move b4 this
is what we want to do and in the game
black simply allowed it with the move
rook c8 and now this is really just
gonna be a tough position for black
after of course the move b4 and this is
just going to be a substantial winning
advantage for white already black's idea
in the game was to play c4 and now what
he wants to do is play the move
c3 why did white not play b4 already the
pond was pinned let's take a look if you
play b4 in this position it's definitely
a playable move but you might run into
the move Queen a7 I think this
tactically is not allowing you to keep
these these pawns connected you have to
do something with them for example a 5
but now black can in fact capture on on
b4 and you're down to just one pawn this
isn't bad for white at all but it's
tough to find a line that's bad for
white in the Banco gambit but the point
is you don't get this ideal setup with
this is why white played rock c1 in the
game just try and force that ideal set
up okay with that in mind
rook c1 in the [ __ ] now rook c8 and now
b4 and now I guess you're asking me
what's the difference why not Queen a7
well the answer is after a five you
can't capture this pawn because this pin
is actually going to be quite relevant
the two rooks would be quite powerful in
this position for example Bishop f8 or
maybe 9 f8 rook takes b4 and the rooks
are kind of dominating so b4 c4 was
black's response and now white simply
plays the move a5 getting these pawns
rolling already threatening to play this
move b5 and it looks difficult to stop
black played the move c3 and now let me
ask you what do you think white played
in response to c3 see if you can find it
at home
see if you can find it what is White's
response to the move see 3 because this
move seems to put a little bit of a
damper on blacks plants our whites
plants just a bit you're interfering
with this Bishop's connection with these
pawns on a B 4 and a 5 and that's gonna
make it a lot more difficult to begin
pushing them so who thinks they see it
who thinks they see it 7 novelty can't
see it it's unfortunate sometimes that's
the way it goes though sometimes that's
just the way it goes oh my gosh the
doulton Stein wants to play b5
immediately the problem with this is not
that the Bishop singing because of
course there is this pin on the C file
although it does get a bit more complex
after this move but I think at the end
of the day wait a second okay at the end
of the day maybe it's okay for white or
something like this but the problem I
was going to say is that this pawn is
also just simply hanging you're giving
up the a pawn by playing this line so
not b5 Gil wolf wants to play rook b3
this move does lose to C takes D to
because there is now this idea with
taking on c1 this is not a true pin
someone says e5 someone says Queen b3
okay let's let's look at the e5 move I
don't really trust the c5 move there's
no need to give up your pawn here and in
fact there is also still this line
followed by taking this pawn so be
careful guys this pin might not be as
real realistic as you think it is okay
someone says Queen b3 that's not a bad
move at all but maybe you're allowing c2
and with some problems on the rook
my goodness nobody has found it yet
nobody nobody in the chat room they've
said almost every legal move except the
correct one Bishop e3 and Bishop g5 are
both okay that's fair enough
Bishop e3 Bishop g5 there
okay moves for white however they're not
the best move like I said it's gonna be
a little bit more difficult for white to
push these pawns if it doesn't have this
Bishop to help along this diagonal and
if you do play Bishop here you are
attacking this pawn but are you taking
this pawn it's a little bit unclear it's
a little bit unclear this Bishop might
end up trapped with some counter play
flora for black here the best move of
course nobody in the chat room found it
maybe if you're watching this video
after the recording you found it
the move is of course you take the free
pawn on c3 everybody free pawn is free
and the idea with this is that if you
play Queen takes c3 well you're gonna
get met with the best move does anybody
see the point the best move well okay
the best move has already been typed in
the chat I think in response to a
different question the move of course is
Queen a4 when after this line you're
gonna get destroyed by these pawns and
this Queen and there's not much you can
do about it
so Queen I fourth was the idea with the
point that you're on this file and on
this night as well in the game if you
play Bishop takes c3 of course I do
wanna mention now rook b3 is working
this pin is realistic now and in the
game black simply played Queen c4 which
is not gonna get the job done either so
fun tactic there for white taking on c3
with this nice idea of Queen a4 that
being said other moves if you don't see
this tactic that are fine but Queen d3
is also a very very nice move the point
is you keep up this pressure on the C
file and you don't yet move this bishop
off of this diagonal and now maybe you
are I'm just simply again threatening to
take on c3 Bishop e1 is also the best
retreating move from the bishop I like
it better than bish of e1 or Bishop
Bishop e3 or Bishop g5 because once
again you might you want this Bishop on
this diagonal so that it can really put
pressure on these pawns meaning
defending the White Queen side
so that these puns are more free to push
we can follow up with something like
right b3 and just take this guy so some
nice tactics there but Bishop takes c3
and after this the game really is over
Queen c4 was played now rook b3 defends
the Bishop rook b8 by black now Queen b1
by white and black does just capture
white goes ahead and captures we see
takes and takes and now it's the Queen
against the two rooks but more relevant
than that are these connected passed
pawns on the Queen side and that is why
white easily wins this game after simply
pushing the pawns up a bit
bringing the night in to c6 and now it's
three connected pass pawns and here
black simply resigned this position and
white ended up winning so once again
just another classic Banco gambit win
for white where you blockade on the
Queen side you bring your pieces over
and from there you're just simply up
upon and you're gonna have a good
position key points to remember in this
game there's a question however so takes
we're saying takes three rook b8 a6 well
okay I mean you can also just take this
guy like this and after it takes b4 rook
c7 and all these pawns fall and this guy
is is not going to fall either for
example here let's seize yeah simply rat
take c7 it's probably good enough you
can take my guy but I'm starting to push
the same game should be lost but maybe
your move is good as well a six here
also seems yeah it seems good seems good
enough to me
okay though so key points to remember in
this game this key break v4 is once
again how white wants to continue after
he is pretty much consolidated on the
Queen side step one in the Benko is
making sure that the black major pieces
don't break through it's all about
preventing blacks play but once you've
achieved that and it's time for you to
find some player on this key break beef
or is is most often the way to do it
this analysis makes the Benko it look
very unappealing it is a very
unappealing opening I do not recommend
it for black you get playable positions
but in these main main lines it's just
really tough you show us some black wins
it's a good opening for black not if
white plays well then again no openings
are good for black if I play as well
some are holding them now I want to take
a look at a game of my own in one of
those sidelines this was game I played
with my good friend Eric Kurtz we played
it online but it was the standard time
control and we're kind of treating it as
a training game so we were taking it
rather seriously just for some context
of the game and in this game I played d4
my opponent played Knight f6 I played c4
now C 5 and we get the Banco gambit now
there was some talk about g6 Knight c3
Bishop g7 and so now we we finally
arrived at this sideline or mainland
Newman whatever you want to call it this
other line for black here now in the
game I played efore black went ahead and
castled and now see if you can find the
move for white there are a few moves
here but the move I'm gonna recommend
has a pretty nice idea with it I think
fragrant's already knows the movies he's
talked about it previously in this
lecture so far nice for black perhaps
and blitz games I mean it's it's an
opening guys you know it's it's a more
risky opening for black it's definitely
on you know the as far as objective
evaluations it's on the lower end for
blacks responses to d4 but I mean it can
be fun of course white doesn't always
play perfectly like Magnus Carlsen yet
fragrance knows both of the main moves
of course the move I'm gonna recommend
is actually this move a seven and it
looks slightly weird to spend a tempo
too
this pawn out of the way but the idea is
you draw this rook to a7 yourself and
now once again a very common idea in the
banco is to play this move Knight b5 in
tandem with a 4 and now 95 is simply
going to be coming with tempo and this
is why I don't really like this line for
black as much as the main stuff even
though I do like the main stuff for
white as as well a 7 is a pretty good
move to draw this rook to a square where
it doesn't want to be now in the game we
continued with simply Knight f3 I'm
getting develops d6 from black going for
more of the standard Bunco plans Bishop
e2 by me and now Bishop a6 was black's
choice still trading off this bishop and
now this is kind of the reason why this
line just doesn't leave a good
impression even if as my chat experts
are saying this is quote-unquote the
main way to play with black now it just
seems as though you're getting a similar
position to the first line except in
this case you're wasting some time okay
so White Castle in this game meaning me
black played Queen c8 which is a little
bit of a strange move more common in
this position is simply developing the
night with Knight pd7
but once again we're just gonna continue
very naturally with moves like a for
keeping in line with the game though
Queen C it
I played the move Knight d2 the idea
being I want to control the c-4 square
Bishop take C to was played Queen take C
to and now Queen a6 was black's choice
now in the game I probably should have
tried to keep the Queens on with a move
like 94 or 95 both very natural moves
would have gotten the job done
I played rook e1 in the game which i
think is a bit of a mistake
black should trade the Queen's here and
go for a more endgame type of position
against these Queen side pawns
in the game though that is it actually
what happened in the game takes and
takes and now Knight g4 but the ideas
for white are still going to be largely
the same here just because the Queens
are off the board
doesn't mean you have to play too much
differently in this case
so I played die p5 rook d7 and now a4
and this is still the best way for white
to kind of blockade on the Queen side
and get these pawns up the board Knight
a six was my opponents chase eyeing this
be for square that I just gave up
but now simply Knight c4 and this is a
very nice hold on the position by these
white knights here night before rook a3
was my choice with the idea that we've
seen beforehand rookie comes on the
board by black and now Bishop f4 was my
choice just getting the bishop develops
guarding this a five square and in the
game my opponent played Bishop d4
putting some pressure on f2 I played
this move h3 note that Knight takes d4
is actually a playable move here but it
does look a little bit uncomfortable to
allow this pawn to to get to d3 like
this it is still fine for white though
in the game though I simply played h3
and my opponent went in for Knight takes
f2 which turns out just not to be a good
sacrifice however I do want to mention
that white has already kind of achieved
an ideal setup here against the Benko so
my opponent was probably feeling a
little bit uncomfortable with the
position and if he had played a normal
move such as 95 well I could simply take
this in after Bishop takes I probably
don't even want to take this guy again I
could but I don't really want to you can
just kind of expand on the Kings side
now with with white actually looking at
moves like f4 looking moves like route
d2 and just for example here there's
some improving moves maybe this
and something like f4 is eventually
going to come on the board and the point
is that White has totally locked things
up on the queenside so black cannot find
any counter play over there and whites
just a bit more free to do these kind of
kingside pawn pushes since the queens
are off the board and so the king is
going to be coming under less less
danger here and whites just gonna
continue with moves like 'if I've really
breaking things open and expanding
that's what would have happened in the
game if my opponent played a
normal-looking move like 95 instead
though Knight takes f2 and now now this
is just simply winning for for white I
believe I chose the Knight takes d4 in
the game night it takes h3 was my
opponent's response much better was
actually to bring this Knight out to d3
when you are getting a temple on the
bishop so you're not losing a full piece
but it is still looking rather rough now
that these ponds are kind of unopposed
with the C pawn missing it's kind of as
though white had played before not quite
because this square is still gonna be a
stronghold for black but without the C
pawn it's it's gonna be very tough for a
black to hold this in the game though
night takes h3g takes h3 and now White's
simply up a piece and the game quickly
concluded well okay this is a little
exchanged SEC by me but I was already at
material so giving some of it back
didn't really change anything
and now the game was once again decided
by these extra pawns on the Queen side
and here my opponent actually resigned
so once again this is another example
where once white gets this nice blockade
on the Queen side the point is black
just doesn't have a lot to play for
that's why priority number one in the
Benko is always always always preventing
blacks Queen side counter play if you
can achieve that then you really have
all the time in the world so you figure
out what you want to do on other sides
of the board and end up winning the game
with these ideas like b4 or in this game
with the Queen's off the board it also
gave white this other idea if
get played normally eventually expanding
on the Kings side with things like f4
and even something like e 5 to follow so
another disaster for black in the bank
oh you got that right the bank goes full
of disasters so I wanted to open it up
now to any question you guys you guys
had on the Benko and then I was gonna go
through these games once again and just
review some really key points where did
black go wrong that's a good question
where did black go wrong well he just
played some slightly strange moves like
Queen c8 here was not the main move it
has been played before and then from
here it takes was good Knight g4 perhaps
this maneuver was just a little bit
flawed in this case maybe better
is bringing this Knight out to d7 bring
this Knight out to p6 and playing on
this side of the board once once again
although I don't think he's that much
worse in this case here even I think
things are still fine but yeah 95 this
would have been a better way to play I
think and white does have a slight edge
here and he does have these plans of
expanding in the center but blacks
definitely still in the game here it's
not not as though white it's just
totally winning
black lost the moment they chose the
Benko you got that one right you got
that one right
[Music]
I always win Benoni / Benko doesn't
matter which color why though I I don't
know sealless that's gonna be a question
you have to answer for yourself maybe
just really understand these positions
so the key ideas I wanted you guys to
keep in mind first and foremost the main
idea of this line the main line is to
bring a knight to b5 and bring upon to
a4 this is what I like white to be doing
in the main line this is how you prevent
blacks queenside counterplay this is how
you gain this blockade to make blacks
life difficult and in this game we
achieved it with the Queen's off the
board which isn't always ideal for white
black is actually sometimes pretty happy
to trade the Queen's but we saw it in
this game we saw it in this game always
this blockade we saw it in this game
this blockade we saw it even in this
game we saw it in all four of these
games this is a really nice idea for
white to block off the Queen side now
beyond this you want to prevent black
from playing the move c4 in all cases in
this case this is why white set up with
this move b3 to prevent c4 and
eventually brought this knight back to
d2 it's all about preventing c4 for
black this is blacks break it's a find
counter play and then beyond that the
the final way to kind of win once you've
achieved your blockade is once again
this break
b4 once you neutralize blacks counter
play you want to play b4 breaking open
on the Queen side and pushing your pawns
to victory well that just about does it
for me tonight looks like you guys don't
have too many other questions why do
people play it if it's so bad well
you'll have to ask a Benko player it
does give some practical chances of
white doesn't know what they're doing
even sometimes the point does know what
they're doing but just has a bad game
but okay that does just about do it for
me thank you so much for joining me this
week on the road to 2000 my name is
Caleb Denby and I will see you next time
[Music]
you
[Music]